[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
all right
well it was the worst of times it was
the worst of times
the united states today it's watergate
911 the civil war the potato famine
and the cancellation of sex in the city
all rolled into one
and thank god due to climate change the
world's supposed to end in eight years
and that reminds me i gotta pick up my
shirts at the cleaners
so why is everything so bad because we
live in the age of hyperbole
in fact some say we're living in the
greatest most incredible era of
hyperbole
since the beginning of time it's where
hacks use extreme rhetoric to scare you
into submission if you don't wear a mask
outside while jogging you have blood on
your hands
if you support the cops you're a racist
with blood on your hands
if you cut your finger slicing tomatoes
well that would be right you would
have blood on your hands but even more
if you disagree with
joe you might just as well be jefferson
davis himself
your soul on free and fair elections is
just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
no he's not well joe biden
literally doesn't know the meaning of
the word
literally i mean he says it's not
hyperbole
because he knew it was hyperbole the
moment he said it
you could say he has hyperbole on the
brain and boy hyperbole must be very
lonely
it's weird how a month of challenging a
contentious election makes you worse
than a pro-slavery confederate
flag-waving
non-recycling democrat but joe's party
spent four years doing the same thing
with the 2016 election
the irony is thicker than brian
stelter's thighs
oh judge you know it's true still the
hyperbole continues
let's see what's happening over at cnn
shall we
the civil war that's not even close no
this is worse
than when lee harvey oswald shot abraham
lincoln it's worse than when the
hindenburg crashed right into that
iceberg it's worse than when all those
good soldiers lost their lives in the
battle of chernobyl
it's worse than when the villagers of
pompeii got wiped out by the bp oil
spill
it's worse than when the manson family
tried to cover up watergates
he got me there little known fact
now remember during the civil war those
confederate democrats may have owned
slaves
but they never put on red hats wandered
into the capitol
and stole office supplies from jerry
the nadler back then never breached the
capitol
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
i'm not saying this alarm you i'm saying
this because you
should be alarmed
[Laughter]
so wait a second pal january 6 shouldn't
have alarmed you because by january 6
you should have already been alarmed
what is going on in that brain
but true we were already alarmed when
you mr magoo
won the election you claimed you were a
unifier
as you deemed half the country a bunch
of nazis how is this rhetoric now
not incitement but keep going
i never thought my entire career i'd
ever have to say it
but i swore a note to you to god
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution
that's an oath that forms a sacred trust
to defend america against all threats
both foreign
and domestic oh man dude you wouldn't
know a foreign threat
if a shirtless putin rode his horse into
the oval office and took a dump on your
desk
so the problem we face as americans
today isn't us it's threat misdiagnosis
russia and china are both engaging in
cyber warfare cuba's looking like it's
ready to blow
and haiti's president was just found
dead with 12 bullets in him
in other words natural causes and in a
dank prison cell somewhere sits a guy
who wore
horns on his head at the capitol but who
does our fearless formerly hairless
commander commander-in-chief c as being
the chief threat
you and me and the network surprise
surprise
agree the questions of when
where and how americans get to vote or
tonight taking on greater
urgency in some of his strongest
language yet president biden today
blasting republican efforts to restrict
voting access
as un-american and a test of our
democracy president biden late today in
philadelphia
the birthplace of american democracy
blasting what he calls
attacks on voting rights republican-led
efforts in more than 16 states across
the country
the president and that warning calling
it the most significant test of our
democracy
since the civil war saying these new
laws aim to limit whether or not your
vote counts at all so solemn so he
paints targets on you
and the media applauds anyway we live in
a time where
rather than use clear plain language to
debate an issue we resort to the
language of the lawsuit
that's your actions are causing
irreparable harm biden's administration
has turned our country into an episode
of divorce court
throwing around terms like vicious and
unconscionable
the dems accuse everyone of every
horrible thing imaginable
imaginable until you sling it right back
at them
then they go from well you're an evil
monster too we ask that you respect our
family's privacy
this incendiary language is spreading on
twitter hyperbole powers the scalp
seeking mobs
and its stench is present in every
online petition demanding a boycott
their targets are always racist and
tolerant authoritarian monsters
even when they're not in power just ask
the gurgling gergen
what we're worried about with with trump
was that he was crazy
and he's still crazy and he was unhinged
and you know didn't and he could bring
the whole system down he's
and he has all these authoritarian
tendencies
it's like an iv drip of concentrated
trump derangement syndrome
is the only thing keeping that
desiccated husk alive
never get to say husk enough and our
hysteric in chief is right behind him
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting and we're going to
challenge it vigorously
we'll be asking my republican friends in
congress and states and cities and
counties
to stand up for god's sake and help
prevent
this concerted effort to undermine our
election
and the sacred right to vote have you no
shame
have you no shame asks the hair sniffing
plagiarizing race baiter
so as a new report reveals that our navy
is unprepared to defend our country
but is full speed ahead on anti-racism
we are being told that the enemy is
within
never mind russia or even china which
now boasts the world's most fearsome
navy
the real monsters drive chevy trucks
wear red hats and listen to toby keith
and we must all go woke or we'll never
shed our evil past
so rather than look forward we focus on
exercising demons from centuries past
all of which were created by democrats
their hate for this country runs deeper
than a chicago pizza
when we inevitably inevitably become a
failed superpower at least we'll know
why
we deserve it because we were worse than
those murderous confederates slave
owners and their corrupt segregationist
descendants
in other words democrats how's that for
hyperbole
[Applause]
period let's welcome tonight's guess
[Applause]
oh yeah she's sent more criminals up the
river than a boat carrying the clintons
justice host
you are a crowd favorite he knows the
beltway like i know the buffet
host of the guy benson show on fox news
radio
go bootsoo
lifeguard lawyer model she handles more
jobs than super glue
turning point usa contributor aaron
ilmore
and her behavior has steroid users
saying
that's not because of contributor catch
it
judge it is a pleasure to have you here
it's like i only saw you a few hours ago
on the five
it was less than that greg it really was
but it's but it seems like a lifetime i
know i know
we need to spend more time together i
don't think so
[Laughter]
no vacations no like you know people do
think you and i hang out
we don't hang out you know why because
you never
you never invite me well you wouldn't
like the things i do i wouldn't
i used to prosecute people for the
things that you did
no she's absolutely right you're right
so judge um yes
this rhetoric okay so trump got a lot of
grief and i would think some of it was
just a file for
for being antagonistic uh but he always
went after
people that were like on his level he'd
go after jim acosta the press
he'd go after the democratic party but
he wouldn't actually label people like
he wouldn't say
blind voters suck or hillary voters suck
he was always about focusing on people
that could fight
biden is like labeling people as like
basically as bad as slave owners and
confederate soldiers well yeah i mean
you know the the
hyperbole as you talk about it is about
making all of us feel that we're racist
we're oppressors
we're horrible people and he references
the civil war
yeah well the civil war was about not
being racist
it was about making sure that people
weren't slaves anymore it was about
americans
dying right 650 000 of them
yet he uses that as an example of what's
un-american i mean i
the guy has lost it he really has lost
it and i think that democrats go to
washington and what they do
is they learn these phrases you're
unamerican you're an oppressor you're a
racist they don't know anything about
the bills
anything about the laws they just know
about name calling
that's what they do okay but i'm gonna
say guy that
both sides i'm not i'm gonna say this
and then i'm gonna contradict myself
okay both sides can be guilty of
hyperbole we we saw a lot of hyperbole
during the obama administration coming
from the right
but i think that this is different
because we our hyperbole is always based
on thinking somebody's wrong
but their host their hostility and
hyperbole is based on thinking
we're evil that's the difference how do
we deal with this
why is biden saying this stuff i think
he wanted to give
a very angry seeming speech to paper
over the fact that he's not calling for
the filibuster to go away
i think he's trying to do like a shiny
object for the left over here but not
actually doing the structural thing that
they want him to do
so that's a serious answer but the more
serious thing that i think i have to say
i think this show right now is an
assault on democracy really
and this this conversation may be the
worst thing that's happened
since the civil war i think you're right
and you should all be ashamed of
yourselves for being a part of it
you know what uh you're saying that now
but wait till the b block oh man
it's gonna be worse than the egg i
cannot help but notice that all of the
ladies are wearing
white is that is that perhaps a little
that's a good idea indicating ashamed of
myself
that's true but and you're also wearing
camouflage camouflage
i'm doing it for the troops
i bet you they appreciate it i'm doing
it for the trip they do i married a
veteran i got you know how they got us
the chat you're supporting one troop i'm
so
i'm definitely i definitely support that
i'm gonna go talk to our our new guest
okay so you just sit there and be polite
well i don't okay i'll try so aaron
welcome to the show
thank you for having me and um the
pleasure's all yours i'm glad you wore
white
i'm very chasing um what do you make of
this uh this
civil war claim and and how is it how
does this help the democrats at
all well basically this is like a real
episode of the housewives of the
democrat party this is a whole season
arc january 6 is the season arc right
right right
and they're using big words and fancy
slogans to try to get them through the
season so they can get to that next
paycheck
right but having said that i mean he
doesn't know what hyperbole is it's not
one of the 31 flavors of baskin robbins
true i mean so he the reason why he's
po'd okay
is because he thought texas's voting law
was too complicated
and didn't want to make it too difficult
for people to vote so like what's
complicated is getting a flat tire or
getting a cavity filled those things are
complicated and inconvenient
showing your id to vote is pretty
standard fare so what does he want
a fair does he want like i don't know a
booth with little girls where he can
sniff their hair
and they can have hunter biden's finger
paints there to show off while you're
waiting to vote what is he asking for
by the way i have to fact check you
those aren't finger paints oh he uses a
straw
and a straw quite good at it he's got a
lot of practice
yeah yeah yeah okay so kat um
i feel like i would be if i was watching
something like cnn i would feel
exhausted because every time i turn it
on there's always a new existential risk
yeah it's so dramatic yes right like
with joe biden he's not
talking to really republicans about this
stuff he's just
saying all this super making these super
dramatic public pronouncements like if
you have
a friend you need to leave that friend
you cancelled dinner plans with her and
she's like that's fine
you go on her instagram she's posting
all these things about like toxic
friends and like yeah so it makes
someone a priority when you're only an
option hashtag so true it's like my
grandma's in the hospital jessica you
know
except like it's worse because it's
tearing the country apart over stuff
that isn't true and is dramatic which is
way worse than just you know jessica
going and
talking to sarah about you i think the
country actually notices
this bifurcating nonsense or is it just
because we're in this
business unfortunately i think it's
because we're in this business
unfortunately i think people
they have other jobs where they're you
know i would say fortunately well yeah
they don't have to sit there and read
well i love my job i mean
you're the luckiest girl in the world
you are you're working with me yeah
we were great yes who wouldn't want to
work with me right judge
yeah i love working with you do you
really yeah no
i think i just believe it
i think they believe it and then people
get so amped up and the culture gets
torn apart like oh if you support this
voting law well then you d then you like
slavery and people just actually think
those things it's awful but but you know
what i think it's not just people who
watch who are in our
i think everybody's mad out there i mean
you look at people like right now when i
drive
i just like look at the wheel i don't
get upset i don't blow the horn i'm
afraid someone's going to show how fast
are you going shoot
stop don't stop it what are you laughing
at
okay so i don't say anything
it's like everybody's so nuts you're
afraid they're going to come at you what
are you driving these days
an airplane what are you driving are you
driving uh
no i'm driving my my suv with my poodles
all right it's my poodles i don't even
know what i'm thinking right now okay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else